[Musique]
première visite d'un chef de l'église
catholique en irak
une visite de trois jours aux enjeux
politiques multiples tout d'abord le
pape souhaite conforter les chrétiens
dans le pays mais aussi dans la région
une communauté très fragilisée depuis
2014 avec l'avènement de dèche et ses
innombrables massacre à l'encontre des
chrétiens d'orient
le pape françois exhorte à l'arrêt des
extrémismes et des violences il est
indispensable d'assurer la participation
de tous les groupes politiques sociaux
et religieux et de garantir les droits
fondamentaux de tous les citoyens
il est fondamental que se taisent les
armes que la diffusion soit limitée ici
et partout que cessent les intérêts
partisans ses intérêts extérieurs ci se
désintéresse de la population locale
intel s11d la population locale
violences assez de violences ce
d'extrémisme deux factions d'intolérance
pour le vatican l'un des enjeux de
taille et de poursuivre voire renouer le
dialogue avec le monde musulman
la communauté chiite en l'occurrence une
étape importante du voyage du souverain
pontife la rencontre ce samedi dans la
ville sainte de nadjaf avec l'ayatollah
ali sistani figure la plus importante du
chiisme irakien présenté comme un modéré
le pape françois temps donc la main aux
chiites après l'avoir tendue aux
sunnites avec l'egypte en 2017 une
visite historique et importante où le
grand ayatollah ali sistani
l'ecclésiastique chiites d'irak et le
pape du vatican se rencontreront c'est
un message au monde et à l'humanité
c'est une certaine unité entre toutes
les religions
cette visite est un événement
considérable qui doit remettre l'irak
sur la carte du monde civilisé estime le
ministre irakien de la culture hassan
nazem le pays est en effet toujours en
proie au terrorisme
un double attentat revendiqué par des
chats fait 32 morts sur un marché de
bagdad le 21 janvier dernier
il est donc plus que jamais nécessaire
d'inverser la tendance en irak
/ plus d'une décennie de guerre et c'est
avec cette visite notamment l'objectif
du président irakien barham saleh pour
l'irak enfin l'autre enjeu d'avenir
majeur de cette visite est économique et
touristique
la pré visite est encore plus importante
que la visite les lieux historiques et
religieux où se rendra le pape en
particulier urbe re-so d'abraham sont
les sites touristiques qui peuvent faire
la prospérité de l'irak de demain des
objectifs qui réclament une sécurité
sans faille et une stabilité politique
qui pour le moment font encore gravement
défaut